Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui, petite vidéo
de vacances au format plutôt carte postale
qui va être en quelque sorte une suite
de ma vidéo sur les propriétés de l'eau.
Aujourd'hui on va se demander,
pourquoi les glaçons refroidissent les boissons.
Et bah ....
parce qu'ils sont froids.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo,
si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la partager...
Non, je déconne.
En fait on va voir que la raison pour laquelle
les glaçons refroidissent les boissons,
ce n'est pas le fait qu'ils soient froids.
Une autre manière de le dire,
c'est qu'un glaçon qui serait à -10°C,
ne va pas beaucoup plus refroidir qu'un glaçon
qui serait simplement à 0°C.
Alors pour comprendre ça, il faut revenir
sur cette idée de refroidir quelque chose.
Quand on met en contact
un corps chaud et un corps froid,
il y a de la chaleur qui va passer
du corps chaud vers le corps froid
et la capacité du corps froid à absorber
de la chaleur en faisant monter sa température,
on appelle ça la capacité calorifique.
Alors pour la glace, la capacité calorifique c'est
à peu près 2 joules (J) par gramme et par degré.
Ça veut dire que si on prend, mettons,
un glaçons de 10 grammes,
il va pouvoir absorber 20 J
par degré d'élévation de sa température.
Si par exemple, il passe de -10°C à 0°C
donc s'il élève sa température de 10°C,
au total, il aura absorbé 200 J,
donc il va prendre 200 J à ma boisson.
Maintenant ce qu'il faut bien voir,
c'est qu'une fois qu'il est à 0°C,
le glaçon ne va pas s'arrêter là, il va fondre.
Et le fait que le glaçon fonde,
ça demande aussi de la chaleur.
C'est-à-dire que pour fondre,
le glaçon à besoin de prendre de la chaleur.
Et la quantité de chaleur qu'il va prendre,
on appelle ça la chaleur de fusion,
c'est à peu près 330 J par gramme.
C'est-à-dire que mon glaçon de 10 grammes,
pour qu'il puisse fondre,
il va falloir qu'il prenne 3300 joules.
Donc si on fait le total, mon glaçon
qui passe de -10°C à 0°C prend 200 joules
et ensuite le simple fait de fondre, il prend 3300 joules.
Donc vous voyez que la quasi-totalité
du pouvoir de refroidissement de mon glaçon
vient du fait qu'il fonde.
C'est pour ça que les glaçons qui ne fondent pas,
par exemple, des glaçons en pierre,
vont avoir un pouvoir de refroidissement
qui va être beaucoup moins bon.
Donc ça marchera beaucoup moins bien,
sauf s'ils sont très massifs,
qu'ils sont très très froid
et que vous en mettez beaucoup.
Cette idée qu'il y ait un changement d'état
et qu'il y ait des transferts de chaleur associés,
en fait on la retrouve dans d'autres situations,
par exemple, quand vous avez de l'eau sur votre peau
qui s'évapore parce qu'il y a du vent,
vous avez froid, et bien c'est pour la même raison.
On le retrouve aussi dans l'autre sens,
par exemple sur les chaufferettes qu'on trouve
et qui peuvent vous chauffer un petit moment.
Elles sont faites dans une substance
qui est généralement de l'acétate de sodium.
Et cette substance,
quand vous déclenchez la chaufferette,
elle va passer de l'état liquide à l'état solide.
En faisant ça il se passe le phénomène inverse,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle va libérer de la chaleur.
Si vous voulez voir comment on fait
de l’acétate de sodium,
je vous encourage à aller voir
une vidéo d'Experimentboy sur le sujet.
Donc voilà, la raison pour laquelle
les glaçons refroidissent les boissons,
ce n'est pas le fait spécialement qu'ils soient froids,
c'est vraiment le fait qu'ils fondent.
Voilà, j'espère que vous regarderez vos glaçons
et vos boissons d'un autre œil cet été.
Merci et à bientôt.